so you think you know every avenger
story
you think you know every challenge
they've ever faced
every member of the team in this episode
we're asking you to think again
welcome to an inside look at marvel's
avengers presented by intel
marvel fans everywhere have followed
heroes such as captain america
iron man hulk thor and black widow for
decades
but crystal dynamics decided early on
that in order for them to reassemble the
avengers
they'd have to find a new face for the
team enter kamala khan
so when we created our interpretation of
kamala khan for the story
it was all about going back to the
source material that's when you're going
to get the core of the character
what makes kamala kamala when willow and
i sat down for the first time trying to
figure out who this young woman
with no name no background no origin was
we realized we really wanted to tell a
story just about the experience of
being young and earnest and
impressionable the comics were
a big part of finding out really what
makes chamola tick and why people
identify with her
the concept of kamala looking up to
people
of wanting to be something when you grow
up it's
the superhero superhero is her ultimate
idea it's her ultimate dream
young kamala is just so hopeful and
excited
and she's a fan girl right i mean who
isn't and it's the avengers we're
talking about here
avengers fans are worldwide they come in
all shapes and sizes
and the one thing we all share is how
much we love these heroes and kamala
has that why kamala became sort of the
perfect choice for us
was that despite it all despite being
affected herself
or labeled inhuman she still thinks
with everything in her core that these
superheroes
are integral to the survival of humanity
first time that i saw just like a sample
gameplay of kamala
was a really emotional moment her powers
are
crazy they let her get huge they let her
punch things really far away kamal has
three heroics she can heal herself
she can do this amazing high five move
where she smashes her hand
into the enemies and they go flying and
she can also enbiggen herself to become
giant
when you activate a heroic it ends up
generating a whole bunch of
physical objects that participate in a
physics simulation
makes that move feel more powerful the
enemies will shatter in more pieces
more the equipment will break into
debris and all that debris will react
to the force that they're exerting on
the world with these heroics
as a combat designer kamala's powers are
the perfect powers you could possibly
have to
develop a gameplay combat system around
i mean she can basically make
any weapon she kind of wants to at sort
of any range she really wants to
and then once we sort of have the high
level framework we put it into more
mechanical terms and figure out like
okay how does this fit with the game
rules
so when kamala grows i mean there's
camera work that needs to be done
there's collision with the enemies where
her collision has grown but the enemies
hasn't
when she grabs an enemy and picks them
up we need to be able to align
an expanded hand with a normal sized
enemy
i think the results really show because
i mean she has the most
innate quick access to doing the most
interesting stuff so
i think especially for our animators
like she was like the character everyone
wanted to get to and it was like i can't
wait till we do this i can't wait till
we do this
at intel we approached crystal with the
idea of collaborating on marvel's
avengers to deliver an enhanced
experience on pc
we could have gone through and added
more red barrels and breakable tables
and things like that but
it wouldn't have been pervasive
throughout the core of the game by
adding
physical objects to the heroics we're
able to bring that experience to the
player
throughout the game when you're playing
kamala you feel
powerful all of these features help you
feel like you are an avenger
in choosing to have aim in our game it
was a big statement because we wanted to
take
a villainous group that many people may
not know about and we think that aim
really deserves to get the spotlight
people essentially
start their journey from a place of
feeling like they are
doing good for everyone else regardless
of what the cost might be
and so at the beginning of the game you
meet some of the founders
of aim george tarleton and monica
rapuccini
the question is always are you really
solving anything or are you just
becoming part of the same chaos and
and that is tarleton's tragedy he wants
to be the winner
he's just this guy who has really great
ideas but nobody cares
from the comic book foundation you know
modoc was sort of an experiment
within aim in some ways the smarter he
gets
the more removed from humanity he gets
and the byproduct is his
look but the the emotional detachment
is the real danger were georges very
reserved uh monica is much more
assertive you know i never really saw
monica as a team player
necessarily i don't think she like plays
that well with others
monica's issue with the superheroes
really is they just sort of stand in her
way because all that matters to her
are her experiments with the inhumans
when they try to sort of stop her from
doing that that is her big conflict
being that they are a science first
organization
a lot of the human element starts to
fall away
in how they're structured when you start
to lose that kind of like
personality inside of the organization
this hive mind kind of becomes a result
so what's a perfect example of that
other than like a honeycomb shape so
that becomes a pretty
prominent design theme that you'll see
across all the aim structures in the
world
you're gonna come up against a wide
variety of aim threats as you play
through the world
of marvel's avengers the collaboration
with intel
and crystal started out about two years
ago we wanted to enhance
what it feels like to take them on the
armor destruction
really enhances the battles and gives
you a more visceral experience
so the heroes can destroy all these
robotic enemies that are in the world
various parts will fall off of them they
can tear parts off of them
we turn them into physics objects and
they remain in the world for an extended
period of time so that later when you
interact with the environment all these
objects are there to react
to the the superhero moves that you make
pieces fly off enemies as you attack
them
you can see that they've been beat up
they're missing armor pieces and it
really
adds a feel of destruction to taking
down
one of those large robots
[Music]
with this type of experience we want to
make sure that we build a world that not
only
is fun to explore and learn more about
its history
but is also going to pave the way for
future storytelling experiences
this is what i love about marvel
everything has to come from story
what locations best serve the story and
what can we celebrate
there's some key places for me i mean
the helicarrier
prior to a day and being able to go
check out all the different things like
cap shield at his booth the iron man
boots seeing the hologram
we were just able to push the creative
vision further and we really invested
hard on the tech in order to make sure
that we'd be able to
support the ambition of the game we
wanted to make to enhance the
environments in marvel's avengers
we chose to add a new water simulation
that's physically based
and allows boats to float on it and
objects that get tossed in to
create a ripple effect and one of the
biggest examples of that is the
helicarrier crash
after the golden gate bridge level it
really looks like
deep ocean water and it behaves like
deep ocean water
and then going back to the helicarrier
after a day
for a lot of things like the helicarrier
that evolve over time
incrementally and in those cases we use
a modular approach
so you have the helicarrier immediately
after a day it's mothballed it's a
derelict
it's it's going unused a destroyed
helicarrier
abandoned rooms the crew quarters you
know oh this is bruce banners from this
is thor's room
and then over time it starts to get
revitalized you know getting to
experience
that and seeing even the restoration of
the helicarrier makes
the helicarrier one of my favorite
locations period you know we picked all
these biomes because we wanted
areas that were very visually distinct
the pacific northwest
utah badlands eastern seaboard some city
environments
we also needed to support all the
different mechanics of various players
so iron man can fly and the hulk can
bound and kamala can
grow and stretch and grab you know
ledges at a distance and pull herself to
them
and you know that's part of sort of even
the traversal at the beginning of the
game was just seeing kamala just going
through
just having fun on the rooftops of
jersey we wanted to at least
represent new jersey and kind of show
her in her element
she knows it she lives it everything
from the design
the feel of the city even the particular
abandoned water tank that she used you
know the team researched
and brought images of those old water
tanks in new jersey
getting to experience these things as a
player
on the stick as kamala as she
experiences
in real time is part of why she is the
perfect choice
i'll take my chances
the world of marvel's avengers takes
familiar characters and gives them new
stakes to create an experience you've
never seen
read and more importantly played before
as exciting as it is to experience a new
story in a new world
in episode 3 we'll show you how it's
even better to reassemble your own team
become an avenger and embrace your
powers
here we go